what do you mean by isn't obviously
simple
so can you give me an example of
something that
is computationally inequivalent yeah
yeah right so so repetitive behavior is
obviously simple
nested fractal behavior is obviously
simple
it's things where
we can readily predict where we can use
a much simpler computation to jump ahead
where we can say uh you know you've
shown me a few steps now i know what's
going to happen i can predict a billion
steps in the future what's going to
happen now all of these concepts
there so so that's what it means to be
computationally that that's what it
means to be not
uh you know to to be to not seem like it
has complicated behavior now as you
start trying to i mean
the thing that's interesting about all
of these principles
is that
as you start trying to put stakes in the
ground of what does this precisely
mathematically mean you realize that the
thing is
it ends up being
you know the principle of computational
equivalence is at some level an abstract
fact about some about rules
it's an abstract fact
um and it can be proved
at least in certain examples as an
abstract fact but you might say
that thing over there i can i don't see
how it's simple
so it must be computationally as
sophisticated as anything but then
somebody can say oh you missed this
particular way in which it was simple
so you know and that's why it isn't as
computationally sophisticated but then
you can say that sort of tautological
because if if it's computationally
sophisticated that's basically the
statement that it doesn't have any
simple way to work out what it does so
it's it's the the thing that's important
about principle of computational
equivalence is that it is a a conceptual
framework for thinking about how things
work that is people had the idea
including me
that you have simple rules you'll have
simple behavior it's not true and this
principle tells you that it is maximally
not true in other words whenever it
seems like it might not be the case that
the behavior is simple it really isn't
and it is sort of as sophisticated as
you can possibly get
so the the um
with respect to speed in real space
that assumption of a maximum upper limit
i think you could derive it
yeah you could derive the upper limit
from the church turing thesis
which is a a sort of subset of the
principle of computational equivalence
so
that so i mean that particular thing is
is not doesn't need pce i think i mean i
think it needs um
uh
to derive the upper limit what what what
is not obvious
is that the typical light cone will have
a surface that is like that in royal
space that needs pce so what it's saying
is the church touring thesis would say
that there exists things that go as fast
as that but not faster
what pce says is your average light cone
in rural space will in fact expand at
that speed
um that's interesting
so so okay so that then
that maximum speed of of um
uh
so the maximum speed and real space
is essentially telling you something
about the actual raw processing power of
the universe
it's telling you
um i mean it's i was i think i'd written
somewhere in a in kind of you could you
could take it in any kind of
computational units but you can say you
know number of wolfram language tokens
processed per second
is by the universe it's kind of one
one way of of measuring that
something we realized recently
is that um
uh coarse graining that is the process
of not looking at every detail but
looking only at a large scale which you
use in statistical mechanics and so on
um
core screening in rural space is making
a higher level description language
so in other words you can make a
description language that's really at
the lowest level where you're actually
describing how every everything works or
you can have a higher level language
which describes only more in in sort of
higher level terms what's going on